i feel like my generation is mad at the
younger generation
like we look at them like they're idiots
and that they're soft and that they're
sensitive but the problem with that is
we made that generation that generation
was inside of us and we released it
welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
episode 84. this episode is a special
one because it was co-hosted by my dad
jordan peterson and we spoke with
russell peters russell peters if you
don't know him is a comedian actor and
producer
we spoke about politically incorrect
humor stand up acting travel working
during the pandemic
universally funny truths spontaneous
action the personality of a comedian and
more i was kind of obsessed with russell
peters as a teenager so this was good
this was filmed a few months ago by the
way back in march i just saved it until
now i have no more saved episodes from
toronto this is the last one
if you do enjoy this please remember to
hit subscribe
this episode is brought to you by
superspeciosa a kratom company
kratom is a herb related to the coffee
plant the leaves or extracts from the
leaves have been used as a stimulant and
a sedative
it works on opiate receptors in the
brain so it's been used to treat chronic
pain digestive ailments and aid in
withdrawal from opiate dependency i
always advocate for dietary changes to
enhance mood or fix things before
anything else diet exercise saunas
sleep but if you're still having trouble
and tried cbd and you felt like it isn't
quite what you're looking for or even if
you like cbd but you also want to try
something else kratom might help kratom
can be great for energy support some
people will use it as a substitute for
coffee or as a pre-workout
some people use it to manage stress
superspeciosa has different strains some
to help you relax some to give you
energy whatever you're looking for they
have it super specious kratom is
reliable third-party lab tested and
approved under the american kratom
association's quality standards program
only natural kratom no other ingredients
remember because this works on opiate
receptors it can cause addiction if you
overdo it so do your research but i've
been someone who's come off of opiates
multiple times from surgeries and wish i
had known about something like this
during that period of time so look it up
and if you want to try kratom and get 20
off go to getsuperleaf.com
enter code mp for 20
off that's
getsuperleaf.com
mp
code mp they're also linked below enjoy
this episode
russell peters and jordan peterson
you're welcome
[Music]
russell peters welcome to the podcast
well hello michaela and jordan
jordan nice to see you
what is the bee
bernd
bernt wow yes it means bear
you know
in ontario yeah
yes well it's norwegian my great
grandfather who built a boat and sailed
it to north america was named barrent
oh wow
yes
people have
pronounced it as burnt my whole life
which also has a certain ring of truth
to it but um berent is good that's
that's solid but burnt
well
have you gone back to norway ever
yes
although i don't know if it's back
exactly
well i mean just to go
visit the motherland your motherland
yes yes i i was there a couple years ago
i've been there many times
are you popular there it's ironically
yes
you seem to be popular everywhere
i mean i'm trying i mean
the the goal for me is to maintain it
yes how's that been with covet and not
being able to tour
well i'm touring right now yeah doing
that like there's only three states
really you can go to at the moment so
florida georgia and texas
so where are you right now i'm in
atlanta
do they limit the number of people in
there is it still fun to do
yeah it's i mean there's only the
maximum is 150 people in the club but
that's fine i mean as long as there's
people and they're laughing i don't
really care how many there are i've done
shows back in the day where there was
like three people in the audience so
you know
anything over three is good i've done
academic lectures like that too
right yes sometimes where there are more
panel members than there are audience
members
yeah that's awesome so you've got to
deal with all that other stuff
i just have to
what sort of stuff do you mean you got
to deal with the panel members and the
board everybody else who wants to come
out and watch you and then and you're
like well i'm not here for you guys i'm
here for those guys
yeah that's rough when there aren't any
of those guys
well there will be
as soon as life gets back to normal
you'll have plenty of those guys
so you're you're in little clubs and
that's a but you're often in stadiums
like which do you like better i mean
the clubs is like being in the gym
you know when you it's like a fighter if
you're if you're training for a fight
you're in your dirty little gym and
you're working out every day and you're
sparring with guys and doing what you
got to do and then when you're ready you
take it to the big stage
right i saw louis ck in a little club in
new york when he was polishing an act a
couple of years ago and
yeah so
i i knew of that that training regimen
so to speak i miss him he's back he's uh
you saw him at the comedy cellar
probably
yes that's right the village yeah that's
where we all came up together me louie
um
everybody chappelle we all came up
through that club too
back in the mid 90s i would go there i
don't even know how i got on i didn't
realize it was a tough club to get in
and on stage from because at the time it
was
we were all coming up so like yeah he's
with us he's good throw him on i'm like
okay cool
that's handy yeah it's very handy
well none of us realized we were going
to be
when none of us realized we were going
to make it we all were just doing this
because that's what we wanted to do
how did you get started in comedy
like how did you decide i want to be a
comedian that seems like something that
nobody can achieve well for me it was i
didn't want to work for anybody
i was just genuinely this is the real
answer i'm genuinely a lazy person
yeah so i didn't know is it that you
didn't want to work or that you didn't
want to work for anybody a bit of both
or both but a bit of both a bit of both
i have a problem with authority so
and i think um
i think you can understand that we we
question things we're critical thinkers
we don't just accept the information i
need to challenge it to make sure that
this is not false information or or
one-sided so
especially when it comes to authority
in those little low-life not low-life
but those places where
they don't really have authority but
they're using some sort of authority
against you i was never good with that i
used to work at aldo shoes at young and
bluer back in the early
90s and uh the district manager didn't
like me so he would always make me do
really annoying things like here change
the shelf right there like that just
really tedious annoying things and one
time i was really sick and he was like
do it and i'm like i was doing it really
slow because i was tired and sick
and he's like what's wrong with you and
i was like just i told can you swear on
this podcast
yeah get the [ __ ] away from me bro
and he was like i'm your supervisor i
don't give a [ __ ] who you are i'm sick i
don't feel good leave me alone
and then they hired a new manager and
then he had told the new manager to
break my balls and then ultimately i
lost the job because i came in late i
got a speeding ticket on lake shore
and the manager was like why are you
late and i said i show him the speeding
ticket he goes this isn't a good enough
answer and i grabbed him i threw him
against the wall and i punched my
stomach and i left
hmm so that's dramatic i mean you know i
was just i just got a ticket and i was
irritated already i didn't have money
you know i don't have money and not
negative money because i got this ticket
and i got this guy being a jerk about it
i'm like this is not going to work
so you don't score very high on
agreeability agreeableness i think as i
get older i do
but i have to respect the person giving
me that those ideas
like gordon is a guy who i respect the
hell out of you could tell me that this
guy's purple and i'd probably believe it
i'd be like you know i think he's right
he's onto something here
well it is purple sometimes when the sun
sets it's true
but there we go we established that
right away
so what's the significance of your hat
oh i just didn't want to do my hair
it's very attractive and your hair as
well it's uh i got a show later and i
don't want to do it early so i was going
to do it after i i did this and then
that's this is my i do jujitsu and this
is my teacher's school so
so i have a question for you a burning
question i watched one of your comedy
specials i think it was from london i
believe so it was in a big auditorium
big arena i mean you had tens of
thousands of people in there which i
thought first of all i thought that was
remarkable that you could pack a whole
arena and so i want to talk a little bit
about that but
what i found so fascinating was that
like your audience was
obviously multicultural
and you were insulting one racial or
ethnic group after another and you could
feel the hunger in the air even through
the television screen
for each race or ethnic group
waiting with baited breath for their
turn to be insulted yes
and so what do you make of that and how
the hell do you get away with it well i
think it's because i touch on things
that when i talk about a certain group
of people
i'm talking about it from their
perspective not my perspective
so the way they read it as they read it
as this guy actually understands us
we can't be offended because he just
said something only we should know about
ourselves
which means he's either an insider or
he's really paid a lot of attention to
us so one way or the other they know
it's done as a tribute as opposed to
making fun of and when you call people
out on certain things like that they're
like wow
how did he know that
okay we can trust this guy
okay so then how do you know that you
have a network of informers like
embedded in racial groups all around the
world no i when i travel around i just
pay attention i like to go to malls when
i
not as much now because uh
you know i i think i've been to most of
the places at least once or twice
already so i'm pretty familiar with the
lay of the land but if i feel like
something's different in the air i'll
definitely go out and investigate what's
happening out there
i asked local people that uh like just
really simple questions you know
what do these people do here how are
these people treated who looks at people
who looks at who is lower and who looks
at people is higher and you know and
then you figure it out from there i i i
determine which way i'm going to go with
this like i was in
i was in uh um
berlin a couple years ago doing shows
i'd never been to berlin before i've
never been to germany before
and uh i noticed so i got on stage and i
said it's so good to be here in in
berlin i tried your local cuisine last
night i had no clue you guys were
i
turkish
turkish food everywhere i enjoyed the
new great german kabob it was fantastic
they want to see you go and see what's
really going on they don't want
they don't want you to come in and be
like oh that was 20 years ago get get
with the times you know
yeah well there's nothing worse than an
outdated comic well it's true i mean
that you have to be on the cutting edge
it can happen to you at any time though
as a company yeah yeah well i also think
it seemed to me that you know you're
giving people credit
by
assuming that they can
laugh at themselves right i mean that's
the hallmark of a pretty well-developed
character the ability to laugh at
yourself and i had some experience with
this when i first
became
reasonably well known
people
noted the similarity of my voice to the
voice of kermit the frog and i saw it
three or four times and i thought oh my
god that i hope that's not true and then
i went and listened to kermit the frog
and i thought oh my god i sound exactly
like kermit the frog i've never put that
together but now that you've said it i
just pictured kermit talking
yes it's really terrible and the guy who
plays saul on uh better call saul oh um
dave bob odenkirk
yes apparently i sound like him too but
anyways many people made much of my
similarity with kermit and then there
was a whole pepe the frog thing and
hundreds of memes and
um they were good-hearted but i i
noticed that there was a testing behind
it you know
if you make fun of someone and they
react badly to it then then you've
you've got some insight into the
negative parts of their character and
if you make fun of them and you allow
them to laugh at themselves then you're
speaking to the part of them that can
transcend their own
prejudice and their own
narrow-mindedness and i really felt that
in the audit in the in the auditorium
that it was such a relief for your
audience to be a place where everybody
could make fun of everyone else and no
one had to be afraid about it and it was
it was all capped off by that strange
phenomenon
that seems so distinctly human that
capacity to laugh which is completely
incomprehensible well for me
you know right away when you talk to
somebody by their body language the tone
of their voice and the way they look at
you like i've been doing this for 32
years now so
for me it's when i talk to them i can
gauge
which way they're taking this
information
and then i could see if they're about if
they want to go left on you and you're
like no no just stay with me i got you i
can go i can ring them back in but
sometimes you you know get guys
it's usually younger guys that have a
bit of an attitude about it they they
think they're cool and they also think
they know things and that's when i
that's when my fatherly instinct kicks
and i go shut up kid listen i'm talking
right now you know
were you
were you always
funny
not peculiar but ha ha
were you a class clown no the class
clown is the loud popular kid
he's kind of the jerk
the comedian is the one sitting at the
back of the class elbowing the guy
beside going look at this [ __ ] idiot
you know the class clown will do
whatever it takes to get a laugh he'll
put on a skirt but he's usually the
popular guy which is why everyone's
laughing
comedian's the one making fun of him i
was not as popular as the class clowns
and and the class clowns were never
funny to me i was always like oh you
suck dude
you know and it would be the guy beside
me who would who would enjoy it or the
you know there was some girls that were
really smart beside me too who would
understand my my way of looking at it
i've heard
this is just
something that i want to throw out
before i forget about it i've heard
you're you have some sort of micro
dosing business yeah i'm the ceo of uh
of a micro dosing company in out of
toronto red light holland
so we're we're um we've got it's legal
now in in the netherlands and it's about
to be legal in
in canada it's also about to be illegal
it's about to be legal in some of the
states
so we're getting ready for this little
boom and it's
it's good for many many things i can't
make any medical claims on it but
it's been known to help people treat
people with depression ptsd
it's definitely a mood enhancer
it's definitely not a downer
um
sadly i've yet to try it
you have yet to try to try because i
can't get it i have to go to the
netherlands to give it a shot you know
but
um soon enough
um joe wrote this is micro dosing with
what mushrooms
hmm yeah and that you said that's about
to become legal in canada i think it's
not far away i would say somewhere in
the next couple of years it should
become legal
there are there are companies now i know
that there's a company in bc that
it's
it's somewhat legal or it's not that
illegal something to
to micro dose
so there are companies i've seen that
will say this is for micro dosing but
here's three grams which right it's up
to you i mean i mean you look it's it's
kind of like drinking you know we
suggest you have one drink but
you know people are sometimes going to
abuse it but i think hopefully we
we get past that because i don't think
it really is meant to help you on a
day-to-day basis
it's uh almost uh i guess in essence
almost like a multivitamin
you know but on a much higher level
i think it'll be good for investing
i know that when when we took off here
definitely good for investing
yeah and so
i've been keeping an eye on these things
so i was interested to see that you want
to be involved jordan
um i hesitate to say yes
i mean you know well i'll
i'll give you the guy's information and
you can contact him if you choose to
well i haven't been in serious trouble
with the media for about three days i
think so it's probably time to do
something that'll what do they come ask
you for
jesus i i don't know really i mean
i
i expected
the attention around me to d to
dissipate three or four years ago
and
for some reason it it doesn't stop
and i can't figure it out really i think
maybe it's because
the media types
i mean some of them have supported me
don't get me wrong but
they can't really figure me out because
what i'm doing isn't really political
it's psychological and i am a clinical
psychologist i've been writing these
books to help people
there's other reasons as well
they have to make everything political
and i don't quite fit that
mold and so
i don't think they know what to do with
me and
they want to put you in a box
yes and then bury the blocks and then
burn the ground and then salt the earth
they want you to say i'm left or i'm
right and you're like listen i'm neither
i'm watching both sides and making my
own decisions
that's how i see you i don't know if
that's true or not but i see you in a
very similar not that i'm wearing equal
footing but i see you in the same way i
see things it's not i'm no i don't pick
a team here i'm just watching both sides
and trying to figure out where the [ __ ]
is the truth
well i hope that that's what i'm doing
that's how i read it
thank you i appreciate that if they're
not getting that that means they're not
smart enough to get you that therefore
they shouldn't be got
well it's it's yeah it's been a great
mystery and it's all come up again this
week so
um i don't know what to say about it
exactly it's
um
stressful yes however it is stressful
mm-hmm um but i mean
the pro that their problem with you is
that you're very articulate
and you enunciate well
and they can't handle that because
they're trying to push you in the corner
to make you uh to sweat and hopefully
hope that you fall apart and i'm like
it's not a facade guys that's really who
this guy is
you're not gonna uh ma that might
actually be part of the problem they
might have been reading things or even
listening to lectures and they're like
well maybe he's got that memorized maybe
this is somewhat of a facade i think
that could be part of it i'll get to the
real thing and then when it doesn't
appear it makes them angry maybe yeah i
don't
we northern albertans are known for
enunciation skills you know you're from
northern alberta
yes i knew where you were from to be
honest i thought you were a toronto guy
no 350 miles northwest of edmonton in a
little town called fairview i know
fairview there was a gig there back in
the day
no
really fairview
26 years ago i did a show in fairview
and i remember going what the [ __ ] is
this place
it was like there was a hockey arena
there
yes and the hotel was part of the hockey
arena
and it had no windows it literally
looked like this room was just like
cement walls i was like am i in jail
and it was freezing
yes it's freezing it's very cold there
yeah it's very cold in canada obviously
but that's a particularly cold part of
canada yes i i know exactly where you're
from where there was a comic back in the
day maybe around
around 96 97 a comic named monty cohen
died out there he was
i think he was going for a run or
something and he got hit by a truck
hmm
and i was it was all bad because i
remember i had lent him uh
these vhs tapes of i used to be a big
kiss fan when i was a kid
that's embarrassing i used to i used to
i found these really cool vhs kiss tapes
and i lent them to him and then he died
i was like damn it how am i gonna get my
kiss tapes back
actually i listened to kiss when i was
13. i have to admit it yeah how old are
you now
oh so you got seven years on me
i thought you were younger than that
you're you're so youthful looking that's
the brown
i'll be 51 this year
so you're not in canada anymore you
relocated to the states
a while ago 15 years ago but
day by day i consider moving back home
every day i'm like you know what
i don't see the purpose of being here
anymore
where are you located i'm in vegas and
los angeles
oh you're in vegas you live in vegas
yeah i've been there for 14 years
that's that must be
a trip
i mean at first you know when when i was
when i first moved out there and i was
in my late 30s it was great you know
you're you're a young guy you got you
suddenly got money
you got no dependents
you're gonna have a blast in vegas at
that time but as you get older you're
like no this is not for me anymore and
uh and you know my kids are both in los
angeles so i have to spend some time
there to see them all the time
i think that's really the only thing
stopping me from moving back to canada
are my kids because i have two different
baby mamas because i'm an idiot
and uh
one i think would let my daughter go but
the other one will not let my son go
that's
that's a different that's a different
part of [ __ ] on its own so
i like l.a
i've been there many times i like l.a
yeah i've seen you but i think
what's that i've seen you on joe rogan's
podcast yeah yeah yeah i have some
friends out in la that i visit quite
frequently so
um but it there are some advantages to
living in canada i i think the advantage
it being it being canada that's the
advantage
it's funny to me when i hear all the
americans go we're not turning into a
socialist country it's socialism like
it's really not that bad guys it's
really not that bad guys you see how
your teeth are crooked and your your
spine is broken well it wouldn't be like
that in canada
because we're socialist [ __ ]
and the taxes are like it's like the
same now i mean at least in canada you
pay high taxes you get something for it
you get better roads and you get health
care
over here you get nothing you might just
get shot that's about it
i'm ready to move somewhere warmer i
thought texas is looking pretty nice
texas is pretty cool though i do like
texas i do uh you're not wrong michaela
so
you're you're how has your comedy
changed and shifted over the years
i think it's become a little bit more uh
introspective i don't think the set that
i'm doing right now is as introspective
as a as the last one was but
um
it's it's a work in progress right now i
don't know
i'm trying to figure out how to uh word
this one the right way because i don't i
want to toe the line you know
and i i
because when you're turning the line
somebody's bound to get offended or take
it the wrong way but i want to make it
so that
if you take it the wrong way i could
show you why you're wrong
so i'm figuring out the wording at the
moment but
you know i'm trying to
cover subjects about you know it's
we're part of you and i are part of the
generation that
i i say that i feel like my generation
is mad at the younger generation
like we look at them like they're idiots
and that they're soft and that they're
sensitive but the problem with that is
we made that generation that generation
was inside of us and we released it
so
i'm trying to figure out the wording
behind all of this because i want to
make it you know i want to make it that
you know you understand that i'm
i recognize that we're mad at you but i
also recognize that i can't stop myself
from being mad at you
well i think every generations tend to
think that the up-and-coming generation
is softer absolutely we all listen mike
i know my parents thought the same thing
and i i bring that up as well you know
my
every time like i said you know my dad
when he would hit me he would tell me
how much less of a beating this was than
he got
you know
so i always like to go the extra mile
and make it extra goofy said my dad tell
me you're lucky this is all you're
getting your grandfather threw a leopard
at me
where'd he get a leopard it was india
they were everywhere
have you had to tone things down in
comedy because like there's a
people well people are all stressed out
anyway because of this whole covid
situation but um some comedians have
been
have been somewhat destroyed and you
tell like you're really funny but you
you veer into
well i would say like a lot of race
jokes and you described them earlier
they're funny and maybe it's because you
cater to the people you're you're joking
about but how have you managed
one how have you managed to i guess
get away with doing that especially with
media
and
yeah that's the main question well
i'm kind of the beauty for me is that
my audience is
loyally my audience so the people that
are getting offended would never have
bought a ticket to see me to begin with
so i can't cater to the to the hater i
gotta cater to the people that are gonna
that enjoy you and want to see what you
do
it's like if your dad just started to
change his tune all of a sudden because
he got influenced by the people telling
him he should watch what he says you
know that would that would make you
untrue to yourself and untrue to your
people and then you'll have literally
nobody because the haters aren't going
to accept you ever
and the people that want to hear what
you have to say you've just turned your
back on them so
i got to stay true to who i am
and i always know my intent when i'm
saying things i know that my intent is
never
to offend or or hurt anybody's feelings
my intent is only to make you laugh
and if you get offended by something i
said then you've got your own personal
issues you're working with
i just happen to trigger them and make
you realize that this is a problem for
you and maybe you need to go see a
psychologist
well i think part of the reason i get
away with
offering people advice let's say is
because i try to include myself in the
group of people to whom i'm offering
advice right
i'm always
thinking
of the ways that i don't live up to my
own expectations and
i think that and i think that's genuine
i don't think it's a front um
i think that
you know you make no shortage of jokes
about your own ethnic group and you're
always
part you're always the bot of your jokes
as well as the person who's telling them
and so the audience can tell that right
away it's obvious that you're not
telling jokes from a position of
superiority it's more like well look
guys you know we're all idiots um yes we
are each idiots in our own particular
ways ethnicity included and here's some
of the foibles but
you know let's not forget that it's
universal truth that we're all fools
yeah i i think that's i mean that's
basically how i approach it because
yeah i in my head there's nobody above
and there's nobody below we're all on
the same playing field
um
you know there's people you admire and
then there's and then there's people
that whatever but to me it's all
literally we're all in the exact same
playing field i talked to you know i
talk to kings and queens and
and and world leaders then i talk to
them the exact same way i talk to my
friends maybe a little bit more
respectful but i don't
fawn over them so to speak i'm not like
yes sir oh what can i do if i'm like oh
shut the [ __ ] up listen dude um you know
i i have i have some you know i'm
friends with the king of jordan and when
him and i talk it's like two guys
talking it's not like
sir how are you oh have you been have
you been pleased so you know it's none
of that it's just like hey ab what's
going on buddy you know
it's it's really cool to have these
kinds of
to be able to be privileged enough to
to get to have the to be put in these
situations and then it's even more of a
privilege to be able to act normal with
them
well it's one of the advantages to being
i would say an artist although comedians
are funny forms of artists but i still
think you belong in that category you're
sort of outside the traditional
hierarchies i mean artists are always
outside the traditional hierarchies that
gives you a kind of freedom that
no one else has it i mean it means also
that you have a very risky lifestyle i
mean for every
i can't imagine how many failed comics
there are for every successful one but
it has to be hundreds and perhaps
thousands
i don't imagine that there's more than
maybe 40 people 50 people in north
america at any time making a living as a
as a comic maybe it's more than that but
it wouldn't be
it wouldn't be a lot more
yeah well you know the thing is there's
a lot of comics that never made it that
are
a hundred times funnier than most of us
that did make it
but for whatever reason
they just never made it something about
them didn't click and i don't understand
it because there's
so many guys that are a hundred times
funnier than myself or any of the top
guys that you've seen
there's guys that have brilliant minds
but they i
they might be their own worst enemy you
know they might just
shun
um victory
so to speak
well you know it's it's it's similar to
inventing a new product in some sense
not only does the product have to work
but you have to be able to sell it and
you have to time the market and so you
have to be the voice for the times and
if you are well
that's not exactly your doing it's
something that's your good fortune
but it can easily not happen to people i
mean there's also there's an endless
number of ways not to be successful oh
yes i'm fully aware of those
especially at the pinnacles of success
you know and and
how do you has there ever been a
comedian that's had larger crowds than
you oh now there's a bunch of them but i
mean i was the first guy to do
um arenas and stadiums
on a consistent basis
and i can still um
say that i'm still
one of the only guys who still does
arenas and stadiums
without being mainstream popular in that
i don't have a tv show i've not i don't
have a bunch of movies behind me i'm not
known as an actor or a movie star known
as a comic
um i mean kevin hart always sounds out
arena's a stadium but he's a big movie
star he's got over 100 million followers
on instagram so i don't even have a
million followers on instagram yet and
people like mock me and i'm like what is
it i don't care i'm a girl that's a
desperate plea by the way from a
canadian comedian for more instagram
followers people out there who are
watching and listening to have some pity
and sign up it's free god damn it
[Music]
how do you not take something free and
then they message me hey can you uh send
me a video saying hi to my dad it's his
birthday and he loves you and i click on
their page you're not even following me
you can't do something free
that doesn't even cost you can mute me
and follow me
i think it's perfectly reasonable of you
to charge the admission price of an
instagram uh following for a
personalized video
to say the least i'm on cameo too so i
can you know
so
how old were you when you were still
unknown like when did you make that
transition from unknown to known so i
started when i was 19.
um
and i started to gain a little bit of
traction in around 95.96
in just the toronto area you know i
started doing these black comedy shows
um kenny robinson started the
uh nubian disciples of prior all black
comedy sundays
at yuck yucks and it was once a month
and having grown up with
from about the age of four most 98 of my
friends were black
because i dealt with a lot of racism in
the 70s from the white kids and it
wasn't a nice place to be so i didn't
hang out with them i was like well i
associate them
with pain
so i'm not going to hang out with them
they were and it was very it was people
like oh rose what would you talk about
it was very ugly it was a very i know
some people say racism
i know what it looks like and sounds
like it has a tone and it has a it has a
certain bite to it there's a venom
attached to it uh when people say things
so i can tell when somebody's jokingly
saying something or if there's a little
bit of something in that you know
and the black community never ever did
that to me there was a couple of times
and a couple of guys but they were just
dicks in general so
um but for the most part
all the guys that grew up and
were black so when the black comedy show
started in 95 i was like this is my
this is my audience like these are my
people and when i went out a lot of them
didn't know me and then when i started
talking about things they were like oh
my god this is our guy
so i got really lucky with that and
kenny robinson started that 26 years ago
we were supposed to have a 25th
anniversary show last year but obviously
i don't know if you guys heard but there
was this cove thing going around
oh yeah this epidemic
yeah i've heard about that
it may not reach canada
wouldn't that be funny if canada was so
slow it just got there in two years
like fashion
no
i don't know what we're doing and i
haven't been i've been home in a year
but uh i would like to know what's going
on with fashion out there are you guys
in alberta right now
no we're in toronto okay there you go
and where the hell did you get that
couch
thank you
i bought it off of facebook marketplace
of uh a very elderly lady was selling it
it had been living in her garage for a
very long time you know what i thought
you were going to say a very elderly
lady died on that couch
well we don't know exactly what has
happened on this couch
it's so it's so retro like i'm
fascinated by it i'm like was that like
a 1960 something couch it's got to be
it might be earlier we uh it
the cushions were solid just toxic waste
and
i had to get everything replaced but
they're nicer now yeah yes she's
inordinately proud of this piece of
furniture so it's good to notice i'm
healthily proud of this couch i mean i
noticed the coffee table in front of you
has that gold trim around it as well so
that's also in tune with the couch so i
see what you're doing there michaela
yeah well she's going for this russian
gangster early disco crazy cat lady
aesthetic and you should see the couch
in her living room it's from the 1970s
it looks like it looks like it was owned
by a greek disco star with excess chest
hair and his shirt open down to here and
you know gold
gold
necklaces dangling all the places you
don't want them to be dangling oh yeah
gambling where you dangle it's
it was apparently untouched in a
showroom for reasons that you'd
understand if you saw it for like 40
years well i think this is a good time
to tell you your daughter told me she's
changing her name to svetlana
so
to match her decor
i can just change my last name to
coracova yeah that's it yeah
yeah my husband's last name is korikov i
just haven't taken it
it's very strange because i named her
after mikhail gorbachev and
i had this house full of russian
realist art and i've been obsessed with
authoritarianism especially of the
communist type and my daughter married a
russian and my daughter my
granddaughter's first language is
russian
so i don't know how the hell any of that
happened lenin as a painting fell on me
when i was a kid when i was sleeping
wham that's that's what happened and uh
just for the people listening not john
lennon either
no no not john lennon
yeah
all those paintings are in storage now
my wife got sick and tired of living
inside a
whatever it was we were living inside
strange soviet museum i guess and now we
have light instead of darkness in the
house i uh was engaged to a girl who was
um
who grew up in the soviet union and then
she moved to america in like 90
she moved america in 92
during the riots
she was to los angeles and
and her mom didn't know anything about
anything
and there was a school that was a magnet
school and she didn't know she just
thought oh it was good for medical if
you want to it's a high school that was
geared towards medical the medical field
and she sent her there but it was in
compton
during the riots
oh man
yes you have to know your geography if
you're going to go uh
go go to an american city yes yeah but
it was pretty funny because she was like
i didn't even notice
she was like i just came from georgia i
didn't notice
yeah so okay so you you started to get
popular in the mid 90s you said and when
did you make the transition so locally i
was between fame i was becoming locally
in toronto
and uh so people would know who i was it
just and it was strictly mostly in the
black community at that time
and
and then i started getting interest from
indian people because they kind of
uh shut me out at the beginning they
didn't they you know they run i'm the
first guy so they're going to be very
there was a lot of trep edition
you know the word i said it wrong but
you know what i'm saying uh
they they were hesitant to accept it i
think it's trepination
you know whatever it is oh no that's
when you get a hole
packed in your gold
trepidation yeah it's trepidation okay
good idea right good um
so they were hesitant so
uh they started like edging towards me
like hmm let's have him host this indian
culture show and i would do it and then
they would get offended because i wasn't
i wasn't like the other indian kids i
wasn't the guy who's going to be like
hello
i didn't grow up like that so don't
expect me to all of a sudden know what
your
what what what your customs are in india
are not the same as what my family's
customs were in india so india being
such a big country with so many
different types of people there's not
one uniform thing
so they're there they started to
this i would either kill or bomb there
was no middle ground for it
and uh and then i started touring around
i started going to england a lot and
from england is where i started seeing
the world
i started going to england in 95
and from england you would get gigs i'd
be like hey russell do you want to go to
northern ireland this week and i'm like
hell yeah so i'd go belfast and derry
and this is at the time when
the ira were bombing uh garbage cans in
london and stuff
they were still
very much big with what they were doing
and uh then you would get gigs and be
like hey do you want to go to belgium do
you want to go to denmark and i was like
yeah yeah yeah and uh i started going
all around the world and i started
really digging it
and that's when i started opening my
eyes to so many different ways and
that's why i think
very early in my career
i was exposed to so many different
countries so it wasn't like being in
toronto and meeting different cultures i
was going to these places and seeing it
firsthand
so
late 90s
you started to get
mass audiences uh no i started
gaining audience popularity when they
would start coming out specifically for
me at clubs would say around 2004 after
my 2003 special had aired
and uh
it's funny because yuck yucks where i
was working
they used
this is how scummy this business is and
this is no slight against them i get it
you're running a business but come on
don't make me feel like i'm getting
something when i'm not
they rely the pay scale for a headliner
was 100
150 or 200 a show so there was a double
a or triple a i was a triple a
um so i was getting 200 a show and uh
they had booked me in the mississauga
yuck yucks
and they called me into the office and
said russell here's we're going to do
something for you that we've never done
before we're going to give you your 200
a show
um but because you're selling so well
we're going to give you an extra dollar
per paid customer
and i said wow that's really cool they
were like is that cool i go that's
fantastic sure great
and the ticket price was 17
well i get to the club didn't they raise
the price to 20 dollars
they got two
yeah well then you were rolling in money
at that point
i think i pulled out eight grand for the
weekend which at the time was a lot of
money yeah like nobody's pulled this
much out of yuck yucks
when did you start okay two questions
one when did you start getting
recognized randomly on the street and
was that transition difficult from not
being recognized because i'm sure after
you're special i think i watched your
special i think everybody i knew watched
your special so
there must have been a transition from
being recognized everywhere from not
being recognized well i see the thing is
i was always like out and about and uh i
don't want to say i was popular but
i would go out a lot and i would and i
was also djing at the time back then so
i if i wasn't doing comedy i was djing
at a club or something
so i always knew like the club
scene and that's really the only place
you could really become popular
and there was no social media back then
so either you were inside or you were
outside so i knew the bouncers the
owners the and i didn't drink at the
time so they never they never had to
worry about me coming their club and
getting drunk and starting problems i
was i was a sober guy until i was about
31
and uh
so i always knew how to get into clubs
free so it kind of felt like i was
already popular because i'd walk there'd
be a line i'd walk up like hey russell
come on in who's with you and i'm and it
was kind of always a cool feeling so
people saw that and then would talk to
you in the club hey man that's all
you're talking about you know the
balcony but you know and then and you
become friends with all these different
people
so when it started happening to him it
just started happening to me more and
more frequently is what happened
so it never really came out of nowhere
just built
and i was honest and i'm one of those
guys who loves people so when people
come and talk to me my security guys
always get annoyed because i stand and
talk to a person i don't i don't go
thank you so much keep it moving i'm
like hey what do you do what's your name
i genuinely want to know about the
person if you're being nice enough to
come and say hi to me the least i could
do is be nice enough to have a
conversation
yeah well it's so it's such an
unbelievable
stroke of good fortune to have
perfect strangers like you yeah that's
what i say
oh man it could be a lot worse oh yeah
because you know yeah and i'm not the
guy you want to come up with an attitude
with because i'm like oh we're gonna
have a problem here pal
and so
if you go out now
just for a random stroll down the street
how likely are you to be recognized in
uh california
it well well you got to tell us about
different places in los angeles there's
celebrities everywhere all the time
cena becomes who's the bigger celebrity
in the room at that point and i geek out
when i see celebs sometimes like holy
[ __ ] that's blah blah blah
yeah i was in montreal
i was in montreal just about 86 i guess
something like that when i just started
graduate school so i just come from
northern alberta alberta and uh i was
walking across sherbrooke street just
south of mcgill university and pier
trudeau
walked across the crosswalk and we were
the only two people on the street and i
went
holy [ __ ] it's trudeau
was he still prime minister then
no no he was he he wasn't at that point
but i would say you know
i know the star struck feeling you know
and that just erupted out of me in a fit
of stupidity and i've always been you
know mortified as a consequence of it
i've done i've said the dumbest things
to people i
you know the worst thing is when you get
in this business and you have nobody you
literally you're the first guy in your
entire family bloodline to have ever and
jumped in this business
and then you're the first indian kid you
you got all these things in your head
and
you don't understand how this industry
works if you've never been around it so
i look at other people and how they
navigate like well that's because that
guy's dad was blah blah blah they know
how to move nice and spluidly i stop and
look at everything because i'm still
stunned by the situations i'm in and i
remember years ago
it's been 25 years ago at montreal just
for laughs somebody said hey
that's the girl that books david
letterman
um and she was a very unattractive woman
let me just say that a very unattractive
woman like
anyway so they said you should go be
nice to her
so you know maybe she puts you on
letterman and i'm like okay and i'm only
96 i'm only been in the business seven
years
i'm you have no business talking to
people unless if you've been in the
business less than 10 years you have no
business doing anything that should
involve that as far as i'm concerned
so we're at this midnight party and
everyone's dancing and there's a free
buffet and everything
and uh
i see her at the buffet and i happen to
be at the buffet and i
i know who she is but i'm trying to play
like i don't
so
i i don't know why i thought this would
be funny or clever or witty it was none
of the above
i just went
wow you must be important she goes why
do you say that i said because all the
pretty girls are out there acting like
idiots
[Laughter]
so did you get booked on letterman never
or did you get macaroni dump down your
shirt she she goes what and i go uh i
just walked away i just walked away
i'm not gonna defend that
so yes i've stuck my foot in my mouth
many times well you'd have to if you're
a comedian yeah i mean that's i think
part of the process
yeah well you're not going to find out
what's funny until you know a bunch of
things that aren't funny and you flub up
a lot i tell people that you're not
going to appreciate success until you've
had failure
and how do you are you good at coping
with failure like i've been fortunate
you know because i haven't bombed in
front of a large audience and that might
be
because
people are willing to give me more
credit than i deserve because they're
you know they're already viewers of mine
and so on but
like i don't i don't know if i could
hack that i i'm not resilient in that
way
and
i i you said that when you were first
starting that you bombed in in many
places listen with comedy you're never
above bombing it doesn't matter who you
are
chappelle can go out and have a bad
night i mean anybody that's the i think
that's what keeps us interested in our
job is that
what's tonight going to be like we don't
people go you're going to kill it i go
we don't know that
yeah i want to kill it i don't know that
it will happen it's up to the audience
what if i get some sort of resistance
from them
last night there was some guy drunk and
yelling out
and and i was getting irritated by it
and you know
i think the older i get the more
short-tempered i'm getting with with
stupidity you know i'm like shut the
[ __ ] up dude you know
i'm like hey what's your name
enough kid enough
and uh so you know that kind of threw
the vibe of the show right off because
they're like oh is he funny tonight or
is he angry what's this guy's problem
you know right right well
i i have an affinity for comedians i
think partly because i hung around with
a group of people when i lived in
northern alberta
and all we ever did was try to make each
other laugh and the the currency of our
social group was laughter if you could
tell a good joke or say something funny
then you scored a point and and it was
great i loved it i and maybe it was part
of the culture too more working-class
culture but
what what i did on my lecture tour i
think was very similar
to what stand-up comedians do
i even attempted now and then to be
funny um
which i can be now and then
but i also
had that
sense of performing without a safety net
you know it was never obvious i think to
the audience and it certainly wasn't
obvious to me whether or not i was going
to have a successful talk because i
didn't know beforehand right and i think
that's something that's so fun about or
so it's so dramatically exciting about
live shows like comedy shows is there is
the ever lurking threat of
disaster and for the comedian it's like
well you're not funny and so then you're
up there trying to be funny and you're
not funny and it's painful for the
audience and it's painful for you and
everyone knows that can happen
and part of the
the thrill is is to be part of that and
watch the potential train wreck unfold
and then everyone's so happy if you are
funny
yeah i mean there's a lot of there's a
lot of variables too with comedy i
remember i was doing this
um show about 15 14 15 years ago was in
dc and uh bono was there from you too
michael mcdonald was going to perform
and i'm sitting at michael mcdonald's
table with him
and padma lakshmi is there and uh
ashley judd and it was like this aids
um awareness
benefit dinner thing and i was to
perform
and
for summer the show started today for
some reason they decided they wanted to
put me on first
but people are still coming in and
people are talking to each other nobody
wants to hear a comedian first
and so i'm up there doing my act and
just nobody's paying attention nobody
like literally nobody
and i could feel my heart beating fast
i'm like mother i'm getting so and i'm
sweating and i'm getting i'm really
stressing out because there's all these
celebrities in this room and i'm like
this is my chance to you know make a
splash here and nobody's paying
attention and not a flop sweat splash
oh yeah well i could have i did make a
splash in my armpits
and uh so i got so mad at them i go
well uh you guys have been horrible i
hope you all got aids good night
did you get any attention for that
nothing nobody i walked off the stage
and right out the building and into my
hotel room or back my hotel room like i
don't want to be here
huh
so you seem like somebody i'm really
interested in personality probably
because i grew up with my dad as a dad
but um
i've always wondered with comedians uh i
had a number of favorite ones when when
i was younger like you were up there
bill burr
um
george carlin carla's my favorite he's
he was so funny um
but i've always wondered what kind of
personality these people have in common
and you come off as
very disagreeable but also volatile
which i i can also identify with but um
dad asked a bit about recovery like how
do you get over having a a bad show
because as a comedian you need to be
fairly resilient so does it just not
phase you yeah you don't drink i mean
that's what comics have that going for
now but i do now but when i didn't i
didn't start drinking until i was 31.
that's that's really late that's really
delicious why
it just never occurred to me literally
it never occurred to me i was just i was
i'm genuinely a happy person so
i i think my fear was always that i
didn't know what i was repressing
i didn't know if i was repressing anger
sadness
um but it turned out the first time i
got drunk
that i just couldn't stop laughing i go
am i repressing happiness what the [ __ ]
is wrong with me
so now when i get drunk i just laugh and
make jokes i just i realize oh no i'm a
happy guy this is great this lets it out
further oh that's good so you're happy
temperamentally and your shadow is also
happy yeah which is a great place to be
god that's for sure that's so fortunate
and you know that doesn't seem to me to
be something that's particularly true of
comics in general though
that they're happy some guys get dark
and you're like okay i don't think this
guy should drink this is not the guy to
be drinking with you want to get drunk
with the guys that are going to laugh
and joke with you
and uh and break your balls because
that's what comics do we have really
dark dark sense of humor uh a very dark
sense of humor like
like you give us a um
like a mass shooting and our reaction is
the same as everyone else's oh my god
but then literally right after oh my god
oh my god oh i thought of something yeah
well that's how our brains go well how
else are you gonna deal with those
horrible things you know i mean
you can tell if you've had a traumatic
occurrence in your past when you've got
over it when you can make a joke out of
it like i listen to my daughter talk
sometimes about her health trouble when
she was a teenager and like she can use
black humor to to make
the people that she's talking with laugh
about it and
that's a sign that it's been dealt with
and thank god we've got humor to deal
with catastrophe because what the hell
else are we going to use
yeah you can rise above it then and i
think that's the problem with this whole
cancel culture thing is that
they don't give you the opportunity to
to look at it the right way
they want you to it it's a very
interesting place when because people
are screaming tolerance and tolerance
and you need to accept this and you need
to accept that
but
at the same time if you're really
preaching tolerance then they need to
accept that these people
are going to need time to accept your
your wishes
so you're gonna have to
we're gonna there's gonna have to be an
exchange here it can't just be you say
you do this and you accept that and
that's the way it is and then we go okay
okay no that's not tolerance
well it'd be a real shame if we started
if we continue to destroy the people we
have that are talented just because they
make a mistake
especially comedians because they're
going to make a mistake they're how can
you not go too far if you're always
trying to get you know because if you're
gonna say something funny you have to be
one
millimeter away from being offensive and
the closer you can get to that the
funnier you are and everyone knows it
because they know that there you are out
on a limb taking a risk
you you want to go oh my god i can't
believe that he just said that and you
laugh and you think oh it's so good that
he just said that because it means it's
acceptable and
you're going to go too far sometimes and
you know what's funny for me is i i'm
performing here in these red states now
and uh i'm not a political guy at all
let's i i don't understand politics i
don't understand either side
but i i do this joke about donald trump
and it has nothing to do with politics
but as soon as i said
one night i was in houston i said the
reason i don't trust donald trump these
three girls got to go [ __ ] you and they
left i go you didn't even hear what i
was gonna say of course that's kind of a
demonstration of why you didn't trust
him yeah well i said the reason i don't
trust him is because he does this when
he talks
i don't trust people that do this
because the only time you see that in
your real life is when something is
wrong like hey man you got that money on
me
so it's on it's almost got this negative
condensation i'm not going to finish the
joke but you got the idea
it was it was good while it was going
but they didn't wait for that part they
you know that's that's the thing is so a
lot of people just jump to these
conclusions because they can't seem to
think that anybody else thinks
differently than they do
so
we're breeding a whole generation of
narcissists
it's not just i swear though
coming from the younger generation
i don't think it's just us now it's
certainly worse at my level and i think
it gets worse the younger you get right
you peaking at maybe
20 or 21. um but
but people's opinions that are older
have also changed it's not like
everybody who's older
is immune to this there are a lot of
people who are older um
that are also perpetuating it
absolutely
it's a it's it's a double-edged sword
but
we we we got to live so much longer
without that
and now we're getting into that whereas
these kids are growing up with it so it
starts much younger um i liken it to
music you know what i mean and
and when
for example i i was a big hip-hop head
growing up
and i've produced hip-hop documentaries
and i'm very involved in the hip-hop
world
but i was part of it because it was this
brand new thing when i was a kid it had
just started and it was like you had to
discover it you had to find it it just
wasn't readily available and i think
that's something like with the same with
the punk rock scene and and the new wave
scene everything was so new when i was a
kid that we were all trying to figure it
out and and grow with it so i always say
that hip-hop gave me my attitude and my
and my way of thinking and the
the the reason i am the being i am today
and now you got these kids that grow up
and hip hop is just there
so it's not something they ever
discovered it was just there and that's
why it got watered down to what it is
now
um
and it's the same thing with the the
social media you're gonna have
you know you got girls in their 20s now
that are selling their pictures on only
fans for five bucks a month uh naked
pictures of themselves and then it's
going to trickle down to like kids in
their early teens now that are going to
be skinning themselves out on instagram
and that's where the parents need to
step in and go that's not that's not the
ch that's not the kid i'm raising
spoken like a true old man
yeah you did a good job with your
daughter you know what i mean i plan to
do a good job with my daughter
yeah well it's nice
yes thank you that's the right answer to
that it's because you don't know me very
well
no i mean i could see the darkness in
your eyes but it's not mean it's more
seized through you
and that's why you can marry a russian
guy because they don't care
i will take what you have and i will
double down on it
you must have spent a fair bit of time
thinking about or perhaps perhaps not
maybe you just make people laugh but
laughter's all been always been a real
mystery to me
you know
if you watch little tiny kids even eight
months or nine months old they already
have a sense of humor yes those are
natural emotions crying and laughter
those really your only two genuine
emotions yeah and there isn't something
that's obviously similar to that among
animals and yet it appears really really
early among human beings and and but
it's really difficult to get a handle on
like it
the best i've been able to do is that
we laugh when
when
we have the the opportunity to sort of
spontaneously transcend our own
limitations
you know as adults
well maybe even maybe even children see
that is is when someone falls down and
then gets up and they're okay they'll
laugh oh yeah i listen people falling
down is my favorite
it's a never-ending source of humor this
is my my remember me i can still
remember to this day
being six years old and walking home
from school with my brother and we used
to have to cross this creek
and the creek was like this and so you
would run down hop the creek and run up
you would just use your momentum to go i
might it was 1976 so my brother's
wearing big [ __ ] kickers remember those
the
seven 1977 the big heels and the big
platform oh yeah i was five foot two i
had six inch platform shoes yeah so
which i regularly fell off of
absolutely but you were five foot eight
by then yes and that was that was a big
difference
i used to have to sit on three phone
books to drive my car
how tall are you now
oh five two
oh wow six yeah it was really it was
really quite sad i know i'm six sorry
i'm six two now
you're you know what i always peg you is
about five eight hey
no that's f that's fighting words go
ahead
a small head
no six and then i'm looking at you and
you read as tall michaela so i'm like
thank you he's got a very tall daughter
for a short guy
you know i didn't know you were six too
you could obviously see my inner
shortness
yeah it's your shortness of breath yeah
it reminds me of a psychiatric syndrome
that i coined once uh short [ __ ]
syndrome
that is a great that is a great term
yeah i'm fighting to have that included
in the diagnostic manuals you should and
get rid of napoleon syndrome change i
have residual short [ __ ] syndrome from
being tiny when i was a teenager
i was small as a kid too i was i was
very little in ninth and
well ninth grade by grade nine by the
end of the grade nine i had grown a
little bit but at the starting of grade
nine i was four foot eleven and seventy
five pounds
oh yeah that's that that's uh familiar
territory i would say and then i had a
huge spurt by grade ten and i was
somewhere around five seven you know
five seven five eight and then by the by
grade 12 i was i'm 5 11 now i'm like i
don't know what happened but it all
worked out in the end
so why do you think people laugh
what do you what is it what is it that
we find funny and and
why do we do it
i don't i don't know why people laugh
but i know that people need to laugh
um
it's something you really need to do for
yourself and you know you i for me the
challenge when i get on stage is when
i'll look for the one person who's not
laughing
and i won't target them directly but
i'll be watching them in the corner of
my eye and i'll see what kind of moves
their body a little bit and then i'll go
down that road until i see them laugh
and then i'm like okay my job's done
that's a good idea
that's interesting because when i'm
talking to an audience i never talk to
the audience i always pick one person no
i don't pick i don't pick the same
person for the whole talk because that
tends to make people very uncomfortable
but i'm always talking to
an identifiable person whom i'm looking
at and because then i can see
reflected in that person
the degree to which my
my words are working and i do watch
as you just pointed out i watch the way
the person moves and i watch the way
their eyes are
are turning and i listen to the audience
as well because
what you want especially
if you've got
a grip on the audience is for there not
to be rustling and sounds you want it to
be quiet and then everyone you know
everyone's focused yeah and if you could
see their eyes dart the minute their
eyes dart something's going on what's
going on here your eyes aren't looking
at me right now
well what are you thinking about is it i
could see it when somebody was thinking
about going to the bathroom because i'll
be talking to them and then i'll notice
them like
and i'll even say that you gotta go to
the bathroom
yeah but i'm scared you're gonna make
fun of me and i'm like no go to the
bathroom jesus i'm not you're not a
hostage
i'm sure people appreciate that
yeah i especially do when women have to
go to the bathroom because women like
why don't you make fun of me i gotta
make fun of you go to the bathroom with
a guy it's a lot easier because i don't
care about them
women you gotta you gotta be a little
bit more a little bit more sensitive and
a little bit more understanding so
when you have a show you're paying
attention to the audience
i'm making assumptions but you have a a
body of of material sort of at hand
now
do you have a completely prepared show
or do you because you said you're paying
attention to the audience members how do
you
how do you how do you do what you do
what's your method
i i come out i know what i'm opening
with and i know what i'm closing with
okay and i know what's going to go in
the middle
but you've got to fill an hour and
opening is about five minutes closing is
about five minutes and the middle is
about five minutes so i've got another
45 minutes to make up for in there and
uh it'll just come to me while i'm
talking to you because i'll talk to you
and i'll ask a question it'll trigger
something else which will lead me to
something else
you know um i had this funny enough i
have this kid opening for me this
weekend
he's um
he was in the audience in tampa two
weeks ago he's a big bodybuilder guy
huge a massive human
and i walked on stage and as soon as i
saw him i go what the [ __ ] is that
i said
when they said build that wall they
meant an actual wall not you
and uh
and i was making fun of making fun of
them
and uh
i said what are you doing he goes
builder i'm gonna go home no no he's i
said i am comedian and i go oh great
this guy's being a jerk right
and he had an accent and where are you
from he's from switzerland and i was
like but you don't look swiss your skin
is a little too not swiss and he was
well my parents are from turkey and i go
okay so i start getting into that i go
you're not you're the alps you know i'm
making fun of them about the size and
then i i ask them again a little later
so what what really what do you do for a
little bit i do comedy and i'm like i
could see it in his face he wasn't lying
so i said all right on the next show i'm
putting you on for five minutes
cut to the next show i put him on for
five minutes this guy kills
like what so i said hey man that was
really good if i'm going to be in
atlanta if you want to come down you can
do some time on my shows so he flew down
and he's you're doing shows this weekend
um i don't know the purpose of telling
you that was but uh he has an accent
what i'm thinking i think the reason is
he has an accent a genuine natural
accent
and he's this giant bodybuilder guy so
when he's talking about americans and
talking about how fat they are and stuff
it doesn't come across as offensive it
comes across that
they look at it they hear it and they go
because he's like well people ask me why
why
how did you get so big it goes i put the
cheeseburger down bro you know it's just
he's he's just really being frank but
it's hilarious to watch because he
doesn't
he knows he's being funny but i don't
think he understands why it's funny
well that you you touched on something
else that's really interesting too
because
comedians are often funniest when
they're telling it the truth
yes right and they what comedians seem
to do is to
they speak the things that the audience
is thinking but won't say or aren't
willing to say
right and
and i mean that's why i suppose there
were jesters in the king's court because
the jester was a fool and so he was
beneath contempt but that meant that he
could he could actually tell the truth
right
and comedians are always doing that and
so i think that's actually a bellwether
for the health of a society
is
if a society can tolerate comedians then
it's still in pretty good shape
yeah when they turn on us i'm like i
don't know what's happening or we really
get confused like what are you turning
on us for turn on the other people lying
to you don't turn on the people telling
you the truth and like they say the
truth is like poetry and everybody hates
poetry
do you do you feel that
i mean do you think our society has in
fact changed so that it's
you know there are comedians who won't
play on university campuses anymore i
know i won't
you will i won't you won't i avoid them
they don't even call me anymore so i'm
pretty grateful for that but
um yeah you know i don't need that i
don't need to be policed by somebody who
doesn't really understand the world
okay so you have seen that change
i've seen it i mean i never had to deal
with it on a first-hand basis i have a
lot of friends who have dealt with that
and uh i even told my agent won't even
entertain a university request nope no
thank you
hmm that's so sad how are those people
gonna be funny
oh they're gonna be funny they'll be
funny elsewhere yeah but they're
supposed to be purposefully funny not
accidentally funny
who the comics are the people
the people who aren't being exposed to
the comedians well i mean
look the way we look at it is it's a
free world we're living in so if you
want to go see comedy go to the club or
go to a concert or something but we're
not going to bring it to you to your
house if you're not really
if you're going to tell us how to do it
are you as enthralled by the business as
you always have been
i'm a little disenchanted with aspects
of it you know
because i think i'm a very genuine
person and i'm and i
you know i i try to be as real as i
possibly can
and if i say i'm your friend i'm your
friend whether you're up or you're down
it doesn't matter to me and i tend to
become friends with people
after their shine is gone so that way it
doesn't look like i was there for the
ride
i wanted to be like you know like a lot
of my friends are old rappers
that i used to have posters of on my
wall as a kid you know they're they're
not living that great they don't have a
lot of money but these are guys i
admired very much and we hang out all
the time we have a great time uh same
thing with comics who i think on my
friends
but i see how this industry is you know
people are for lack of a better term
dick writers
and uh
i see them all padding it they all fall
we all follow each other but i see their
page and i see who's commenting on who
and who's liking and i look on my page
like none of these guys i go but if
something popped off tomorrow with like
i became the hot
guy in the media it was like russell
peterson
every one of those people will be
messaging me and i'm like i see you
already so don't let it happen to you
i i so i i don't ever want to be like
those people
so i always tell people there's no
friends in this business
well i suppose one of it's a cliche in
some sense but i suppose that one of the
dangers of becoming well known is that
it isn't always obvious why people are
associating with you
right
right i mean i have a you know i have a
situation in my personal life that uh is
a result of that so
it's the reason i have a son you know
what i mean
yeah well
kids i got duped well it's also not easy
for
you know once you become well known it's
it's not that surprising that people are
affected by everything that comes in the
aftermath of that i mean it really is
overwhelming and
and
and compelling and so
it's not like it's easy for an external
observer to separate your fame from you
right
especially if they're not familiar with
that world
you know they don't know what what you
went through to get to where you are
they don't know
what your upbringing was they don't know
what kind of household you grew up in
i think especially in america because
the uh
the uh the indian community in america
is
is the highest um
it is the uh wealthiest
minority group in the country
and so they all grew up uh upper middle
class to wealthy in america it's not
like in canada where we have poor indian
people and then you know we we we have
different levels of us over there
and so i think they automatically
associate me with those ones over here
and go he had a privileged life i'm like
no my mom worked in kmart my dad was a
chicken meat was a meat inspector we did
not have a privileged life you know to
us an exciting uh the big move for us
was in 1986 my dad bought a cutless
sierra used from hertz
and it had air conditioning and we're
like yo we finally got air conditioning
in the car we didn't have it in the
house but we had it in the car and my
dad wouldn't turn it on because it would
waste too much gas
it's going to be a special day for him
to turn that ac on
uh it's way easier to
look at somebody that perhaps you're
jealous of and assume that the reason
they got there is out of luck rather
than hard work because that means you
don't have to put in any hard work
because you couldn't get there anyway
right they negate you they try to uh you
know they try to marginalize what it is
you've accomplished well and there is
luck associated with it too as we
already
described
you know you you're in the right place
at the right time and you could have
been
talented in
at the wrong time it happens all the
time to people
so
but the fact that it's blocked i think
sorry
it's much easier to hate on somebody
than it is to
uh show them the the respect and love
that you think that they rightfully
deserve
and your fans you sound like you're
treated very well by your fans they're
always great to me they they're so loyal
yes and i've experienced the same thing
i'm so grateful to for to my viewers and
listeners and readers they're so they've
been so good to me i can't believe it it
just
it just shocks me and i'm i'm hoping
constantly that i don't do anything to
that would be disappointing
so
well that you're like me because you
don't you know you want to walk the
tight rope but you don't want to
disappoint i get it 100 what you're
saying it's
getting there is one thing and then
maintaining it as a whole another animal
yes well especially when all of us are
deeply flawed
oh man i know i know about all that yeah
well yeah so i i heard about a project
that you're doing i don't know whether
or not this is true but are you doing
something with the comedian just rain
yeah just rain wrote a a tv series he
gave us a script and then my brother and
i are executive producing it
okay i think it's for cte or cbc one of
them
so you you haven't
had a sitcom you haven't been in movies
um
why not
i mean i've been in movies just you know
little small scenes here and there and
that's fine
um i initially got into this because i
wanted to be an actor and then i
realized i have
i quite enjoy stand up a lot more
you know you get into a movie situation
and you got to do these 12 to 14 hour
days which i'm not a fan of
and out of those 12 to 14 hour days you
may be only working four
but there you are waiting around bored
to death sitting in this wardrobe that
and you're mindless that you're you're
you're you it's it's dizzyingly boring
and the financial reward isn't the same
and so it's for me it's like oh god this
sucks i can't wait to get out of here
and just go be free again you feel like
i feel like a prisoner when i'm on a
movie set
well yes doing doing a movie acting in a
movie is very much different than doing
stand-up comedy having to repeat scenes
too i can't imagine having i just get
frustrated having to repeat scenes over
and over and over and everything's
recorded out of sync so it's not like
acting in the play either yeah it's not
even yet they may start you know the the
middle of the movie
and start shooting at the middle and
then shoot the beginning at the end and
the end at the beginning you never know
they it depends on here's where we're
shooting all these things are going to
take place here they're going to shoot
them all
in there of course
they're not going to keep continually
going back to the field that they were
shooting in you know so yeah wardrobe
changed this look that look everything
and
man there's so many people uh first a d
once and then uh they want you on set in
15 minutes and i'm always arguing with
them really because are you going to be
ready for me in 15 minutes no we just
need you standing by i don't need to
stand by
you know it's a fast it's a fascinating
thing to watch i worked as a grips
assistant on a movie shoot in la for
about two weeks weirdly enough
and it was fascinating i had no idea how
movies were made but it's it's uh
it's it requires a very certain type of
skill and it doesn't seem to me that
there's much overlap between that and
being a stand-up comedian especially one
who who
who's spontaneous like and as you
described your own
your own comedy you have this
massive store of material that you can
draw on
um
i i it seems to me
it seems to me like jazz improvisation
yeah it's very much the same as that you
know like uh without the heroine um
you know it's cold train without the
heroin really
sometimes you just go up and well that's
how i do it i like to just
just you know see where see where we go
yeah well that that that also captures
the audience because you take them along
for the ride that way right so that's
also something that's musical because
when i'm lecturing to an audience i'm
always paying attention to them and i i
know where i'm going to start and i have
like eight points in mind that are like
the skeleton of the lecture you know and
so i can always return to them but then
i'll go out on tangents and and many
people don't like that style of speaking
but if i'm in decent shape i can
go out on a tangent and come back to the
main story but i can do that in concert
with the audience and then they're and
they're integrally involved in the
entire process and that's what makes the
lecture come alive
yeah i mean
that's that's the beauty of it that's
also the part that keeps
us as the person speaking interested
because otherwise it just becomes some
sort of performance art and it's just
boring
you know i i don't wanna it's a recital
at that point and i don't wanna
feel like i'm reciting this night by
night i want you to feel like you had an
individual experience with me this night
like i saw you last weekend the night
you were talking to blah blah blah and i
go oh yeah that night i remember that
and then and also talking to people
spawns new ideas um you know and like
you said you go out on that tangent
because you you got triggered
and it and it and it made you think of a
whole other way of looking at the
situation
yeah it's very it's great privilege to
be able to do that and to and to have
the audience there to to to help it
along
yeah it's it's fun i think it keeps us
all interested in it
um but sometimes you know i go on these
tangents and they don't end up in a
funny place and i'm like oh well
we tried guys
and then i'll go into something i know
was gonna work but you know sometimes it
doesn't go the way we want it to
so what's in the future for you i don't
know
um that's what i get for asking a
cliched question yeah i mean who knows
what's in the future um what do you want
to be in the future for you like what
are you hoping for just listen to
after the past year we've had i just
want
what was normal again to be
you know i don't like watching movies
and seeing like a an audience scene or
like you know i'm like remember that i
don't want that to become a memory i
want that to go back to reality
yeah no kidding it's
all those things we took for granted
yeah it literally and it's just you know
i think it's their way of
bringing us back in or you know reining
us back in all right guys here here
we're going to take these things away
from you remember we took all everything
away only to take a little bit away now
but they still wanted to take these
things away from us and i don't
understand the purpose of it but
whatever whatever will be will be i
suppose
if if that's the plan i think it'll
backfire i mean after the spanish flew
didn't they have the roaring twenties
like it seems like we're mimicking that
everybody's gonna go like
i am anyway gonna go insane after this
lockdown being an extroverted person
like i think there'll be a boom in
nightlife so if this is trying to keep
us under control i don't know if that's
a
good way to do it and we we hope it goes
by i mean i've been
listening atlanta's wide open i've been
going to the cigar lounge every night
after the shows
oh my god
yeah well it's it's quite distressing to
walk down queen street in toronto right
now
yeah you know queen street for everybody
who doesn't know is the it's kind of the
cool commercial district of toronto
there's many of them but it's perhaps
the main one and
you walk down queen street and every
fourth or fifth store is boarded up and
you think of all these people who've
poured their lives into these beautiful
little boutiques and restaurants and
and they're all
well suffering dreadfully away and it
was so good that we had them and
god i hope they come back
i can't see how people are making it
through all of this being shut down for
so long a lot of people aren't yeah i
think the majority of them are not
making it through this
and uh
in la especially it's the same thing you
drive down ventura boulevard and
uh i would say one uh
one in every three shops is closed like
done
yeah well in those little businesses
they take they take a lot of work to
open and a lot of work to maintain and a
lot of capital and
it's it affects everybody on every level
it's not like you know the landlords are
taking a beating because the people
renting their space can't pay their rent
and then they have to
i don't understand their purpose of
forcing them out well i don't know you
forcing them out i mean
you're not gonna get any more money from
what you're just gonna so it there's a
lot of
there's a lot of panic happening and i
don't like to see that kind of
uncontrolled panic in the world it
bothers me
yeah well we are in a situation where
pretty much every decision that people
make is a bad one yeah and it's all
arbitrary so people are going you
shouldn't do this you shouldn't do that
well though they're doing it here and
they're not doing it there and
you know you're not socially distancing
i'm in a place where they don't do that
you know so do i which which laws do i
follow right now do i follow where i'm
at or do i follow where i'm from or
where i'm going i don't understand
[Music]
yeah
yeah my mom is in la right now and i got
her the shot already
so she's gonna get her second shot and i
think in a couple of weeks but then one
of my friends called me from toronto i
was like hey you know when your mom
comes home she's gonna have to uh
hold up quarantine in a hotel and i'm
like why she lives by herself can't she
go to her house like i don't know
they're saying that she can't and i'm
like but she lives by herself in a house
yeah around her she should be able to go
to her house and she's got the
certificate saying she's been immunized
i mean is there no [ __ ]
concern
for things
you get tested you get tested to get on
the plane so you have to test negative
that i don't mind i mean i can get that
i understand that to a certain degree
but even if you test negative and have
the vaccine you have to quarantine for
three days to get your test results in
canada you're not allowed to leave your
room they give you a br like the
sandwiched in water there's pictures
online of this room it's you get brought
there by the police
um and the halls are monitored by guards
and then you go home for the rest of
your 14-day quarantine quarantine even
though you have a negative test and are
possibly vaccinated
yeah i can't let my 80 year old mother
be treated like that i'm not gonna yeah
i'm just gonna keep her until they
uh their sanity comes back
yeah well the politicians can't keep up
with the continually changing
circumstances so
it's it's very sad
so
you're on a tour you have these three
states you can go to and these three
states i can go to and i see other dates
coming up in uh in march i think utah
and indiana
something in uh pennsylvania so it's
it's opening up slowly but surely
um and i'm only taking the work because
i'm going broke sitting at home
i've already had to downsize a lot you
know i i
cut a lot of people off my payroll
i had to sell them i had to sell my
house and move to a smaller house and i
mean it's not a woe is me situation
because it's not like i i'm i move from
you know from one house to the ghetto
you know i moved from twelve thousand
feet square feet to eight thousand
square feet oh whoop-dee-doo you know
what i mean so it's not like i'm
suffering but it does hurt on an on a
certain level i've worked so hard to get
to that and then i have to move
backwards but you know whatever it is
what it is and you also start to figure
out what was necessary and what was not
necessary
um i got rid of three or four cars i
didn't need that many cars and i
realized now why the [ __ ] was i wasting
my money on all these cars
i sold some watches i was like i was
getting rid of things i'm just like
these are things that don't matter and i
realize now
what matters and i'm like okay i got the
one house i got two cars i'm good to go
yes and actually you need zero watches
because i suspect you probably have a
phone
yeah but i like watches yeah i like
watches too i have one
so what are you wearing today there
jordan
i am wearing an omega nice so you see
you're a practical guy
was it omega that asked me
i was asked to be a spokesperson for
omega watches well that's not a bad deal
at all me and daniel craig
that happened about a year and a half
ago and i was sorely tempted to do it
because
it was so ridiculously cool in my
estimation that
asked to be a spokesperson along with
daniel craig it's ridiculous it was so
ridiculous that i really wanted to do it
you didn't do it no
i didn't walk around and said your bond
jordan bond yes yes i know i know what
the b is for
well you asked at the beginning of the
show
yes it was one of the more surreal
invitations that i've had
yeah that would have been a good deal
i've never been asked to promote nothing
not one thing have i been asked to
promote how many you want to stop aids
give it to me to promote no
how many shows do you have coming up
i got two tonight and two tomorrow
and which i actually i got to start
getting ready for yes
we should let you go we're we're very
happy that you agreed to do this talk
especially it was i got to tell you i
was really honored to be asked to do
your podcast
uh i told did you see my question in
your uh instagram
i didn't i got so many people are so
excited but did you know that i watch
all of your dad's videos on youtube
i'm gonna find that and screenshot it
and save it as my save it as my
screensaver well i'm i'm i'm
pleased as well that you're not
uh you didn't have any qualms about
appearing with me because
that has been a problem for people no i
was my brother i called my brother my
brother's like he's awesome that's
amazing
well say hi to him for me oh yeah he
lives in oakville so he's gonna see this
when it comes out oh yes and subscribe
to russell on instagram please yes and
youtube you can go to my youtube channel
i have there i have over a million
followers i'm happy about that because
that's a little bit better for me but uh
and then i have my new podcast coming
out uh soon it's called culturally
cancelled
when is it starting i've already shot
i've already recorded six episodes and
uh i think it's going to start in march
if i'm not mistaken
ah good luck with that well let us know
around march 2 and i'll tweet it out and
all of that yes and if you find yourself
in los angeles i would love to have you
on
that would be really fun i i've the the
interviews that i've enjoyed the most
have always been with comedians yeah i
mean i would pair us up with another
comedian too so we could just make it
really ridiculous
thank you and thank you jordan thanks
for doing what you do both of you and
look at this kid you raised
give yourself a pat on the back
hey thanks a lot and thanks for all the
humor man thank you it's so much
appreciated it's so wonderful to be able
to laugh and and take care of your
health for me please would you
i we need you you can't go anywhere we
need you
thank you russell thank you very much
extremely necessary
thank you sir it was a pleasure meeting
you i hope we can meet in person
absolutely 100
bye guys
[Music]
you